I think we're just about ready to learn
how to subtract pretty much any number
from any other number so let's just
review a little bit of what we know
already so if I were to ask you what 16
minus 4 is I could draw 16 apples and
then take away 4 the apples or I could
actually draw a number line and actually
let me do it here just to start off the
video to get warmed up I could draw the
number line maybe that's 16
maybe that's 17 its 15 14 13 12 let me
go down all the way to 11 I could keep
going but I've run out of space now if I
don't know in my head what 16 minus 4 is
and it's a pretty good one to eventually
know in your head you could start in
your number line or you could imagine
the number line in your brain and you
could go down by 4 16 minus 1 is 15
minus 2 is 14 minus 3 is 13 minus 4 is
12 and you would have the answer 16
minus 4 is 12 now an even easier way to
do this problem an even easier way to do
this problem is just to focus on the
places of the digits now let me be clear
what I mean when I say that let me
rewrite it 16 minus 4 and I've gone over
this a little bit in the Edition videos
this is the ones place the ones place
the 6 is in the ones place the 4 is in
the ones place the one right here this
right here or if I if there's something
down here this column that is the tens
place
that's the tens place now what do we
mean by that well 16 16 is the same
thing as 10 plus 6 so when we write it
this one literally means 110 if you
thought of think of it as money means
one ten dollar bill if I had a two there
if I had 26 that means two ten dollar
bills to ten dollar bills would mean 20
dollars so that's two ten dollar bills
and then six one dollar bills you can
see this is the one dollar bill place
that's the ten dollar bill please if I
had 355 let me do it 357 you could view
this as three 100 dollar bills
five ten dollar bills and seven $1 bills
and that's why that this is called the
hundreds
that's the hundreds place this is the
tens place and this is the ones place
and we'll we'll dig a little bit deeper
into this as we explore borrowing and
regrouping more in this video and in
others but I wanted to label these
places because what I want to show you
is you don't even have to think about
16-4 you can actually just look at just
the ones place and think about six minus
four and say six minus four well you
could draw a number line or you could
even use your fingers if you have to but
you probably have that memorize you
could probably visualize in your head 6
minus 4 is 2 6 minus 4 is 2 and then 1
then we go to the tens place 1 minus
nothing there's nothing over here so 1
minus nothing is 1 and you get 12 same
answer we're able to simplify a little
bit let's try another problem like that
if I were to ask you what 78 minus 30
minus 37 is so we start off in the ones
place and we say 8 minus 7 that's 8 ones
minus 7 ones or just 8 minus 7
8 minus 7 is equal to 1 8 minus 7 is
equal to 1 then we go to the tens place
7 minus 3 now remember this is seven 10s
or seven $10 bills
minus 3 $10 bills if I had 7 $10 bills
and I give away three of those $10 bills
then I'll have four $10 bills or seven
minus three is equal to four and just
like that we were able to figure out
that 78 minus 37 is 41 and you know this
would have been really hard to do it are
taking you forever to draw 78 apples in
to cross out 37 of them or to draw a
number line all the way up to 78 and
then go back 37 spaces that would have
given you the answer but it would have
taken you forever to solve it that way
and just by focusing on just each column
you're able to get the right answer well
you might say hey Sal but what happens
if I can't if well let me give you an
example where this will start to become
doing it this way I'll do one more
example like this so let's say I had
let's say I had 95 - 31
just like that 5 minus 1 is 4 9 minus 3
is 6 95 minus 31 is 64 you're probably
saying Sal subtraction is easy I can
just look at each place the ones place
and subtract tens place and subtract but
I'm about to show you that it's not
always at least that easy but with a
little bit of practice hopefully you'll
realize it it's also not too bad
let me so what if I were to ask you what
22 minus 17 is 22 minus 17 now once
again I could draw 22 oranges or apples
and take away 17 of them and you could
count what's left and you would get the
right answer but that would take you
forever is there any way I could do that
maybe just on the paper right here now
you want your reaction mighty let me
just do what you just did before but if
you look here if I try to subtract 7
from 2 like if I have 2 things at least
4 what the mathematics that we know
right now I can't give away 7 I only
have 2 to give away this would give me
something smaller than 0 which we don't
know about it that's a negative number I
can't as far as we know right now we
can't subtract 7 from 2 but we know that
17 is smaller than 22 so what can we do
here to actually do this subtraction
problem so what we do here is and the
you know you might call it borrowing you
might call it regrouping this 2 right
here this 22 is the same thing as 20
plus 2 that's the 22 right there it's 20
plus 2 the 17 is 10 plus 7 that's just
another way to write 17 now we have a 2
here we want something larger than a 7
to subtract from so we can do is we can
borrow from this 2 or from this 20
they're the same thing this let me do
that in another color this 2 right here
is the same thing as that 20 it's just
another way for a 2 in the tens place
means to $10 bills to $10 bills is the
same thing as $20 that's what that two
rep
so if I want to make this two into
something larger why don't I take a $10
bill from here if I take a $10 bill from
here and I turn it into once I go to the
cash cashier and say give me a bunch of
ones so if I take a $10 bill from here
then I'll this will become $10 and then
I cash into a bunch of ones and put it
here so then this will become $12 if we
look over here what it looks like I did
is I took a one from this two so this
two will now become a one right it went
from two tens to 110 it became just one
$10 bill and then I gave that one to
this to this two then becomes a 12 and
now we can actually subtract 12 minus 7
is 5 12 minus 7 I'm just doing the same
problem just written slightly different
on this right hand side is also 5 and
then we have 1 minus 1 is 0 I could
write this as 0 5 but that's just the
same thing as 5 and here I'd have 10
minus 10 well 10 minus 10 is just 0 so
it's just 0 5 so 22 minus 17 is 5 let's
look let's try to extend this to an even
harder problem and hopefully you'll get
the hang of how this borrowing or
regrouping depending on how you want to
view it actually works so let's say that
we have 703 minus 67 so if I try the
technique that we learned earlier in
this video I immediately hit a roadblock
I say 3 minus 7 well that G that's you
know if I have 3 apples I can't take
away 7 from there so I'm at an impasse I
don't know what to do next and you say
well maybe I can borrow but I got look
to the left I feel G there's a zero
there how can I borrow from a zero and
then the well those are 7 there but then
how do I borrow from the 7 and all of
that and the best way to think about it
and the more practice you do the better
remember the 703 is seven hundred seven
hundred dollar bills plus zero ten
dollar bills plus three one dollar bills
and 67 is six ten dollar bills or $60
plus seven so if we can't borrow from
here because I have no ten dollar bills
what we want to do is break
is break one of the hundred dollar bills
so what I do is I take a hundred dollar
bill from here so now I'm left with 600
dollars so this seven becomes a six
right it's a six in the hundreds place
it represents six hundreds six $100
bills so then I remember I took out a
hundred dollar bill and now what I can
do is I can split that hundred dollar
bill I can give ten dollars to this guy
or sorry I can give ninety dollars to
this guy right here and then I can give
one dollar to this guy I'm sorry I could
give ninety-nine sorry I could give
ninety dollars to this guy that I can
give ten dollars to that guy right there
I have a hundred dollars to work with
right so what happens if I do that if I
take that hundred dollar bill that I
took out from your went to the cash
register I got nine tens or ninety
dollars so now I have nine tens here and
then I have ten ones here so I add ten
plus three it becomes thirteen and just
like that all my numbers in each column
if I were to draw columns like this
divide them up everything on top is
bigger than everything on the bottom so
now I can subtract so 13 minus seven is
six nine minus three
I'm sorry 9 minus 6 is 3 6 minus nothing
is 6 so 703 minus 67 is 636 now you
might be saying okay so I kind of get
what you did you took 100 from here you
put 90 here so that's became a nine you
gave 10 here but how did you know to do
that or what's the more systematic way
of doing it you know this kind of is the
conceptual way which is in my mind the
most important way to understand it but
let's let me show you a kind of a
mechanical way to do that so let's say
we have 700 I'll do the same problem
over again 703 minus 67 I look at all of
the numbers on the top and I say are
they all larger than the numbers on the
bottom I see well 3 107 is larger than 3
that's not good 6 is larger than 0
that's not good so I need to do
something so what I do is I start with
this 3 right here and I say well can I
borrow from this number to the left and
I look to the number to the left and I
cannot borrow from 0 so then I look to
the two numbers to the left and say can
I borrow from 70 and I say well gee I
can definitely
our Oh from 70 we know this is actually
700 so if I borrow from 70 what happens
if I borrow 110 from 70 70 becomes 70
becomes 69 right if I borrow 1 from 70
it becomes 69 and I take that one and I
it's essentially a 10 right so that 10
plus 3 is now 13 and not these were my
columns just just like that and you have
13 minus 7 is 6 9 minus 6 is 3 and then
6 right down here now another way
another way you can think about it I'll
do the exact same problem 703 minus 67
you can start at the left you could say
look 7 is well it's larger than what's
below it nothing is blowed so I'm cool
there and then you go 1 right to the
right of it and you say well 0 well 0 is
not bigger than what's below it it's not
bigger than the 6 below it so I'm going
to need to borrow so what I can do is I
can borrow 1 from the 7 I'm essentially
borrowing 100 right so if I borrow this
is 700 let me make it 600 now if I take
a hundred away and I turn into tens
that's 10 tens it looks like we took a 1
away and we just put the 1 in front of
the zero but we essentially added 10
tens to it but if it helps your mind we
took a 1 away from this put it right in
front of the zero just like that right
if this this is the same zero as that
zero right there and this one we took
from this guy he became six and we have
a 1 there and then we say okay 10 is
definitely greater than 6 we're cool
there but all of a sudden here on the 3
we're still not good 3 is smaller than 7
still not cool I won't be able to
subtract so let me borrow again now I
have something to borrow from remember
we went from the left to right this time
set up from the right to left all of
these are valid ways of doing it so we
we say let me borrow 1 from the 10 so 10
minus 1 is 9 and let me give that one to
the 3 to go 13 remember it's not a 1 I
actually get I added 10 to it if I take
1 from the tens place that's like adding
10 to the ones place don't want to
confuse you hopefully you see the system
here
that's the I want you be able to do the
problems before you you have to get the
you know the real deep understanding of
what's going on so 13 minus 7 is 6 9
minus 6 is 3 6 minus 0 is 6 636 let's do
a couple of more problems because the
subtraction sometimes with the borrowing
it can come a little bit confusing on
what to do next let's say 953 - 754 and
maybe we'll do it in all of the
different ways that you can actually do
this type of problem so the first one of
the ways I talked about like to start at
the right see 3 larger than 4 no it's
not so we're gonna have to make it
larger than 4 so let's borrow from this
5 over here so you'll say so let me do
that right here so if I if I borrow from
the 5 the 5 will become a 4 and I
borrowed 1 the 3 becomes a 13 remember
if I borrow 1 from the tens place that's
actually a 10 all right this is five
tens I took one of the tens away so I'm
left with four tens and I added that 10
to the three so I have 13 so this looks
good 13 - 4 I'll be able to subtract
there but here I have a problem 4 is
less than 5 it was cool before but now
sudden it's messed up so I'm gonna have
to borrow again I'm going to say well
let me take off one of the one from the
hundreds place so that'll become an 8
and let me give that hundred to my tens
place 100 is 10 tens so I'm going to add
a 10 here so it's going to become 14
right I took the 1 from there and I
borrowed it alright or I rearranged that
hundred I could rewrite that hundred is
110 and so that's what got us to that
for me 9 - 8 or sorry 100 I took away
100 from the 900 to get 800 and when I
rewrote the 100 in the tens place it's
10 tens so that's why it's I added a 10
to the 4 that I had before I could have
just crashed it out and put the 14 like
that to show that I had to rewrite the 4
but now sudden I'm cool 13 - 4 13 minus
4 is 9 14 minus 5 is 9 8 minus 7 is 1
953 minus 750 for
is 199 now let's do it the left-to-right
way 953 let's use a different color -
754 now this is a this is it'll be a
little bit different than I did last
time say well 9 is definitely larger
than 7 let's see 5 is definitely larger
well at least it's equal to 5 so if I
subtract maybe I'll get a 0 there but in
3 is less than 4 so let me sow something
maybe I'll just have to borrow here if I
borrow here then this is going to become
a 4 that I'm have to borrow from there
I'll go above 14 it'll essentially boil
down to what we did on this left-hand
side right here instead one thing you
can do is say ok 9 is larger than 7
that's that's cool or even better you
could say 953 is larger than 754 you
know that you know that this is going to
be a positive number that this number is
larger than that then you go what shift
over 1 to the left is 53 larger than 54
well no 53 is not larger than 54 and
because 53 is not larger than 54 let's
borrow let's borrow from the hundreds
place so this will become an 8 and we
have a hundred to work with so maybe
we'll just pull that hundreds right here
well so well if we throw the hundred in
the detent place it's 10 tens so the 5
becomes 15 right we're going from left
to right so now we say 8 is larger than
7 or well 8 is definitely larger than 7
15 is definitely larger than 5 and then
here once again we see 3 is less than 4
but now we can borrow from the 15 so if
we borrow from the 15 the 15 becomes a
14 and then the 3 becomes a 13 because
you take one away from the tens place 1
10 dollar bill is equal to 10 ones so
that's why you added 10 to the 3 you got
13 and notice we ended up really with
the same thing no matter how we did this
problem so just like that you get 13
minus 4 is 9 14 minus 5 is 9 8 minus 7
is 1 hopefully you found that pretty
straightforward
these are frankly as hard as the
borrowing problems get the ones where
you don't know have something to borrow
from or when you do borrow from it all
of a sudden it's it's hard to
you get a number that it'll then need to
borrow from something else and if you
ever get really confused about it you
should always go back to this you should
always go back to this notion of
regrouping this notion of okay if these
things are all too small let me take a
hundred-dollar bill over here so I have
six hundred dollar bills left let me
regroup that hundred dollar bills into
the other spaces in this case we took
the hundred dollar bill and we put 90
here or nine tens nine $10 bills and
then ten dollars of it right there to
make everything in the numerator larger
than everything in the denominator